you wanna do the intro for me it's
what's poppin its what is poppin hey
guys so this interview is split into
three parts if you're new to this
channel you probably came here for part
one now for part two and three this is
for my subscribers for people who care
about Sunmi not a lot of people do but
for some of you here is the chance to
get to know her and yeah it's pretty fun
and I hope you guys learned something
and I hope you guys have fun watching
this video what's poppin guys welcome to
another tech show where we give tips and
tricks on how to land a successful
career in tech you're just moving your
oh cool so today as you can see we have
a special guest Asami hi everyone I'm
sunny not the kpop star unfortunately
just they just start for engineer but
you know it's better than nothing
today what we're going to talk about
we're just gonna talk about somebody's
journey on how she got into software
engineering and it was highly requested
so you know and she was also requested
to be on my videos that's why I asked
her here cuz she begged me so alright
carry on
let's see oh wow okay so so so before we
begin short bullet questions Mac or PC
Mac nice iPhone or Android
I felt easy choice favorite language
Korean favorite programming language Oh
favorite programming language nice nice
I like Python - favorite editor oh no no
so I used to use them but no I think I'm
a suspect
really all right coffee or tea coffee
nice hint or lacroix what wait wait why
do you work across so much here that
like the sparkling water
dude hidden has sparkling water by the
way I don't know that yeah
hey the water new product market okay
cool alright so let's talk about your
journey to software engineering where'd
you go to high school and I went to high
school in China actually wait Korean I'm
Korean so I was born in Korea and I was
there until in the Bible entry school
and then I went to Beijing or my mostly
high school Oh fascinating fascinating
so wait so why did you go to China
I think it was a combination of my dad
sort as well as my mom wanted to give me
better education by sending me to a job
yes so did you do any CS classes we are
there no no so wait when was also done
haven't you oh really
yeah mine either so but like most
apparently most American schools yes
high school yeah okay and then when I
know what you were to do after after
high school I came to the US for college
or do Stanford Stanford I've never heard
of it what is it
yeah it's just like school and
California I suppose it's and
paultalkers
is it good for anything like okay is it
I've heard of this whole campus I heard
it's Palace by average
it's like Waterloo but United States did
you go to Waterloo [ __ ] I know what
it is okay cool cool yeah so how did you
get in Sanford I mean I mostly applied
did you have to do like I said hey do
you do SATs in Turin
in town okay what was their SAT score 23
it doesn't mean much to me it's pretty
impressive
all right yeah so so at Stanford what
you study
okay yeah and then but Stanford was like
the only time that you first learn how
to code right yep I actually did not
know how to code at all before coming to
Stanford so yeah my first CS class was
actually wasn't a Java classes
programming fundamentals that was hot in
some form of Java so that was your first
course I was my very first exposure to
programming yeah and then I guess you
fell in love it yeah I really liked the
professor who taught classes because
effort places all of their celebrity for
concerns into their classes so that
everyone will get on it and then they'll
get hooked on so they will take this yes
so then I'm guessing just to four CS
classes and then more and more did you
do any internships yeah I did - the two
internships one at apt and I did one so
abt would you do a make a software
engineer and a LinkedIn I was a manager
oh so you did both like what you like
more of them they're really different I
mean I'm gonna do right now so I also
really drilled engineering but they're
really different PM is much less
technical at least the role I thought
was pretty not very technical and
engineering
let's make sense now are you an engineer
and then what kind of engineer are you
I'm uh I work mostly on pockets so do
you ever think about trying like iOS or
Android or do you like back-end you want
to stay I think I will not be really
solid and lucky before I expand but I'm
definitely interested in okay did you
get a lot of good grades in school I did
nice nice
don't what like like college I would say
college I did you get along a great
thing do you think that matters for for
getting hired for internships in college
I would say I did get good grades
but it does not really matter
mm-hmm okay so not that much so what
matters more is like your experience hmm
so what about like your first internship
because I'm guessing you didn't have any
experience before I guess if you are
freshman and looking for a very first
internship you need to show everything
you can in order to prove yourself
so GPA would help but then again it's
only a freshman GPA so it doesn't mean
that much but it's better than a really
low champion so did you study a lot for
for the grades of God like like where
you're just studying all day like that
score did you do a lot of
extracurriculars that wasn't often a lot
of different student groups okay so I
think it was a healthy balance of
studying and also meeting new people
especially in here you have to meet new
people that's like well freshman year is
for right so I don't know if you did
that I don't know ah yo okay funny story
so I lived in the dorm and our dorm was
next to a club like like I'm pretty
ragged like law really yeah it was it
was called Phil's or something because I
lived at Laurier people from Waterloo
you would understand but yeah and every
every Wednesday night oh you're like and
I would just be just like alone oh you
know studying
yeah I mean I wasn't alone I got friends
but just I didn't like to go out okay no
it's antisocial have you thought
anything yeah like side projects because
I've heard new experience is better than
like grades you know they care of
experience a lot so did you do the side
projects and those helped I had never
really do side projects but I worked
part time at a foreign startup mmm
but that was it was just purely for
experience it wasn't like I was getting
paid or anything so it was almost like a
side project so I was just calling for
them so what did you do it is start up
mostly development as well as Road
mapping because that startup you don't
really have separate roles like one
person does everything yeah so how'd you
even like apply the jobs like did you
have career fairs or did you like apply
just on the website so I did it there
with multiple channels
I want to career fairs because Stanford
ask a lot of career fairs I just applied
online and also got referrals when you
got you know your internships like did
you study for damnably how would you
study for now for interviews huh um yeah
you definitely have to say for them I
don't think just taking classes is
enough for coding interviews at least
unless you have a class in college that
caters specifically towards interviewing
skills um I think one book that everyone
recommends and they recommend it for a
good reason is cracking the coding
interview they have all the basics they
have the solutions for questions as well
so it's pretty earth it 2/3 through it
and then afterwards I just went online
when I leaked co-packer ranked those
things so that you can actually practice
like OPM interviews I was also in a
group called Stanford consulting so I
have done some consulting interviews
before and although they are pretty
different it does helped to have some
consulting guesstimation type of
backgrounds and then having okay I know
why I didn't get the job now for context
I just want to put this out there
Oh
like I didn't know her before I just
knew her now but like before I remember
I actually applied for the LinkedIn role
as a p.m. same year I did not get in so
in some ways we cross paths and she took
away my only opportunity to become a
p.m. why instead I went to Microsoft you
still working for Microsoft as a p.m.
how are you in high school like where
you'd like the nerdy time or like that
not that nerdy time you know that's not
cool no I I didn't quit cult I just man
they're too tired and not there's any
type you know what I thought was nerdy
nerd okay no but like what why like for
example did you join like clubs like
robotics or mobile blog like that what
kind of clothes you join actually I was
only like music related clothes so I
wasn't in academic clubs I guess I
considered myself because I did study a
lot so when I wasn't like though I don't
know this is a fish of a typical nerd
who like really doesn't socialize
okay cool cool yeah so what about now
like what do you do outside of work
after our long work hours so if I don't
want to socialize oh just watch TV
Korean drama reality show which Korean
dramas eh I recently I've been watching
this like really intense one which is
called cold it's like money flower okay
translates in like for us really intense
story of how the super rich family
fights for their heritage classic
classic wait is it a love story or is it
no it's like oh there's a lot of love
story incited but I think a lot of
intensity so if you weren't a software
engineer what do you think you would
have done instead being realistic I
think I want to either
for their consulting or banking okay
what is it what if you could do whatever
you want everything pays the same
whatever I want everything pays the same
but you can't say like I want to be a
travel blogger travel blogger I know
that that makes sense yeah travel
blogger or a food critic a food critic
yeah
just hey but yeah I'm ready
oh yeah the writer fine have you ever
written something about food yeah oh
yeah well I don't share with us but you
but you do right yeah but mostly when
I'm like not really happy with it either
what I'm not really happy with it we're
like really happy with it
I should find your yoke account okay my
elf it's all like one sorry
really yeah yeah it's like there's no
reason to rate it good yeah yeah yeah
are you a member
yeah no no okay I don't write that much
so what about okay so now you know a new
grass off for engineering do you see
yourself doing this for a while like
what's your like five-year plan um if I
were to stay in engineering I like [ __ ]
for becoming an engineering manager
otherwise I think I would want to play
more of a cockerel now I guess what
we're gonna do now is that we had a lot
of viewers question and in case you
don't know I have a disc or channel and
that is where everyone asks the
questions disc or channel is on the
description below if you want to join
that disc or chat what's really cool we
talk about random stuff it's a great
community yeah so some of these
questions you know very career related
some of them less so first one career
related what was your APM internship
like you know quick answer a lot of I
met a lot of new people which was the
best part a lot of working professionals
and a completely different experience I
was very different from coding this one
less career oriented if you were at
convincing Joel must crush to data what
qualities of his would you bring up
first if I haven't he if you have any
hmm on a scale to 1 to 10 how annoying
is DOMA Wow
Thanks more like actually I'll be nicer
and more like 12
what'd you say nice do you watch anime
I used to which ones I used to well I
didn't watch anime I used to read though
I read like one piece Naruto classic
yeah do you think Jonah is secretly gay
100% gay
oh yeah maybe like 0.1% out but I'm
pretty confident okay any Loki talent or
Bobby hated any Loki talent or hobby
okay hobby I mean you don't need to
force it if you have no talents it's
fine just go to the next question I'd
like to do I like to play golf I like to
or really try to sing oh nice ie I like
to bake oh babe nice nice nice
alright if you were to start a YouTube
channel what kind of videos what you
want to make and they all want to make
casual videos like lifestyle type of
videos when I travel I want to film
whatever I'm eating the everyone wants
to do that I see so I see you're a big
lover of food interesting explains the
figure alright so these are all right
what were your first impression of Jolla
my first impression of them honestly I
thought it was really annoying
there's a reason for it so the first
time I met Sunmi I thought she was
really [ __ ] to be honest and the
reason why is because we're on the same
team and everyone scattered for lunch
and I would usually you know crack some
jokes you know tell some nice stories
everyone would laugh except for
something she would had that [ __ ] face
that you see all the time in the startup
series
that was why I casted her to be honest
so then I was like god damn it man why
can't I like I don't understand I need
to crack her right so then I just
started talking to more on the hey how's
it going and then I you know cracker and
then maybe that's why they're good well
I think you're laughing out of
politeness yeah but yeah I'll be fine
I mean first impressions don't she's
fine too so I guess this is kind of
similar but what is drama like at work I
guess we can talk about what I am like
now Jonah works hard on his videos this
should be oh I don't know about work but
he's working hard on something so
there's this time when Joel also next to
me and he was like having a lot of code
so I thought wow this guy is like
actually working this time so Kathy
Rovers like oh what you're working at
and then I saw him just writing a lot of
HTML code clearly data scientists don't
write I'm like okay you're clearly not
working on your real work you're making
your website I was making my merch shop
yeah that one time I was going to be
like yeah Joe actually working like I
was literally like this like earphones
on me yeah so I'm like hi mm-hmm
so apparently I have 2% Korean
viewership 2% 2% and one of them yeah 2%
Koreans and then one of them says say
something to your Korean fans you know
Inc
maybe cool Korean fans know they are
talking on TV what Jesus often say oh
yeah you know and too much time T job
I'm sorry Timmy 201 done pretty key mark
okay about cockatoo and quality video
Connie what team on career chromatophore
go go positive thoughts more come from
me back come suddenly does neither thank
you so much for your kind words
[Music]
Timmy 201 John key mark
okay mock cockatoo and quality video
Connie what team on career chromatophore
go go positive thoughts more time phone
me back come suddenly dad thank you so
much for your kind words
yeah alright so that's about it
that's it for now I just want to say
thank you so much for watching this
video if you liked it don't forget to
press the subscribe button and also
press the bell button if you want to get
notified whenever I go lie or whenever I
post a new video and don't forget to
follow me and who else
I know it's just me on instagram is
Jalapa Oh fine he gets like ah follow me
on my Instagram is Jomo ha thank you
thanks for watching
outro
[Music]
okay not touch me please okay not touch
my keyboard you please
especially nice crotch the [ __ ] okay